hi there steve kaufman here um
today i want to talk primarily about how
i learn words because that was a request
i had from one of the people who follows
me here at youtube how do i learn words
um
first of all before i get into that let
me just say that i've been experimenting
with using google plus hangouts
for discussions with uh primarily with
our link learners to explain some of the
functions of the new uh
you know new version of link linked to
2.0 and so forth and i found the
experience extremely frustrating uh it
may be because i'm technically inept but
it seems that
i go to invite people who come who sign
up they want to be there and then they
don't get invited or it's just been a
mess uh the link page at google plus it
seems that there's like
four or five or six postings of the same
hangout i don't know what's going on
and i must say that in general i find
this whole world of twitter facebook
google plus linkedin
whatever
uh i mean i only use it as a means of
trying to spread the word about link i
certainly don't follow anyone there
um
you know after this
little video i'm going to settle down
with a book i have a spanish hangout
tomorrow at 8 so i'm going to read a
book in spanish i haven't quite decided
what i have a book on spanish history i
have
el sor sombrero de tres picos which i
have never read and then there's a book
about the functioning of the brain in
spanish i'll choose one of them and
settle down for a couple of hours in
peace and quiet and just to get away
from this uh all this constant chirping
that comes at you on these uh
on these social sites but that's another
issue words okay to me language learning
is primarily about acquiring words
i firmly believe that
and that is why at link the most
important
uh statistic that we track is the number
of words you know
we don't necessarily think the number is
accurate
scientific but it's an indication of
your relative improvement in the
language
now let me backtrack a bit i can still
remember when i i hitchhiked on a boat a
small german
uh
[ __ ] steamer going from montreal to
europe a 19
whatever it was 62 62-63 i found work i
just two three days i went down to the
docks of montreal and i asked if i could
work my way across the atlantic and
finally there was this one
german trap steamer they'd lost a sailor
in quebec city and they said fine
and i still remember sitting there in my
cabin at night going over these
declension tables for german
hoping that somehow that would help me
to speak
and it really didn't
um
and of course then i studied in france
and i didn't do any of that sort of
stuff with french mind you i had had
french in school but mostly when i was
studying i was reading books because i
had to i was at university in french i
had to write essays in french i had to
read tons of stuff in in in french of
course i had a dictionary hand in i was
looking up words
uh so then the next language that i went
after was chinese where i was assigned
by the canadian
trade commissioner service to learn
chinese
and there again what i did was
in order to learn words i only
read
books which had glossaries i refused to
go after any material where i had to use
a dictionary because it was so time
consuming
and of course we all know that any word
we look up we're going to forget right
away so it was a tremendously
frustrating to spend all this time
counting strokes or going by the uh what
they call the radical
component of the chinese character in
order to find this character in order to
find out what it
meant i just went with glossaries and i
did better than
anyone else who was studying chinese at
that time in hong kong and i believe
it's because i read so much i read and
read and read i had a huge library every
book that was put out
on on in chinese with glossaries i had
it and i'd read it until i got to the
point after seven or eight months where
i actually could read without the
glossaries
so
i'm kind of leading to how you acquire
words which was the question you acquire
words through input in my opinion
um again
at link now link to my mind is the most
efficient way to acquire words you don't
need the glossaries the problem with the
glossary is
that it's kind of behind the chapter or
at the back of the book so you come to a
word you don't know you look it up in
the glossary half the time it isn't
there but on the other hand there's a
bunch of words in that glossary that you
already know in other words the person
who wrote the book can't anticipate
which words you know in which words you
don't know nowadays with online
dictionaries you don't have to do that
you can read the online dictionary gives
you the word right away that's not to
say that you know the word because you
looked it up you don't
the
definitions you find in the dictionary
may not even suit the context that
you're reading but it gives you a bit of
a half a hint and then you encounter
with the word again and again and again
and each time you get a better sense of
how that word is used
and of course we do this at link and
every time you say a word is highlighted
in yellow and that reminds you that you
once looked it up and then you go in and
look at the definition definition again
because you've forgotten that you might
add to the definition adjust it or
whatever
but the surprising thing is
that in both russian and czech where i
have very good statistics
i have learned more words like i know
more words that i never looked up
than
those words that i looked up so if i
have saved 30 000 links at link
maybe 20 000 words and 10 000 phrases or
25 000 words and 10 000 phrases but um
our statistics say that i have 75 000
words whatever that statistic means but
i know for a fact that nowadays if i
import a text from a russian book or a
russian website you know there's five
percent words that i don't know there
very few words that i don't know so i
have learned an awful lot of words most
of them i have learned
through listening and reading i am a
very sporadic flash card i don't do it
regularly only because i don't have the
time i have an hour an hour and a half a
day
and not every day to spend on language
learning so i'm going to do things that
i enjoy doing which means reading and
listening i'm not going to sit down and
flip through flashcards most of the time
if i had six or seven hours then
obviously it's good to vary the kind of
activity you're engaged in so then i
might spend more time flashcarding so to
me
overwhelmingly you learn words through
listening and reading
and there are little things you can do
to help you
personally i think the yellow
highlighting in our texts the way we do
at link helps you
i will occasionally look at a word and
see all the examples that we have
because that helps me see how that word
is used because there are words that you
see
and you always seem to have only a 60
sense of how that word is used and you
would like to nail it down even the
dictionary definition doesn't nail it
down for you but if i see 10 examples of
how that word is used in different
contexts that starts you know it moves
me along because after all you're
constantly kind of moving from that
initial exposure to the word
to where you finally are confident that
you know how that word is used
so i learn words listening and reading
now there are people who say you can't
claim that you know a word until you can
use it
i don't agree
all right
i feel that your passive vocabulary will
always exceed your active vocabulary in
a foreign language by quite an amount
because if you're talking to native
speakers they're going to have a much
bigger vocabulary than you do and you
have to be able to understand what
they're saying you can choose
from a more limited range of words to
express your thoughts but you need a
much larger vocabulary to make sure you
understand what they're saying similarly
if you're reading books if you're
watching movies
if you're listening to a radio program
you need a larger passive vocabulary to
make sure you understand so it's normal
you have a smaller active vocabulary and
the passive vocabulary is basically the
foundation for the active vocabulary
you're not likely to have an active word
you know part of your active vocabulary
that isn't already in your passive
vocabulary it starts in the passive to
my mind everything starts with
understanding if you can understand you
can learn to speak and the way to
acquire words is to focus on
understanding focus on listening and
reading and just
listen and read as much as you possibly
can and obviously to speak well you have
to speak a lot but until as i've said
before until you have enough words and
enough
of a sense of familiarity with the
language any conversation you're going
to have is so limited that i consider to
be not a meaningful conversation the
kind of conversation you can only have
with a tutor or a friend
and personally
i would rather spend an hour or two that
i have a day
engaging with more meaningful content
even it's if it's passively listening
and reading rather than having some kind
of a make conversation with someone just
so that i can practice saying the
limited things that i know how to say in
the language i would rather wait until
i'm able to have a meaningful
conversation and that's what i do in
czech and and in russian we have
meaningful conversations we talk about
politics we talk about history we talk
about things that are going on in canada
or in those countries and those are
meaningful conversations and that to me
is where i want to get to but i begin
with this focus on understanding and
learning words and overwhelmingly i
learn them through massive listening and
reading so whoever it was who asked me
how do you learn words
that's how you learn words
and you say okay well you can't read if
you don't know the words that's right
you start with small
short
content items
preferably where you also have the audio
to reinforce it
you have some way of looking up the
words you don't know
and keeping track of those words you can
do it with pencil and writing out lists
or you can do it the way we do at length
or you can transfer them to flash cards
the anki
whatever system you want but you have to
have some way
that you are
gradually increasing the length and the
level of sophistication of the content
you're listening to and somehow keeping
track of your accumulation of vocabulary
again there are people who say that you
should go use you know graded readers
and always have this uh you know
95
of the words should be known to you this
sort of n plus one only slightly sort of
too difficult for me that's too slow
because if i did that in check
you know i would still be reading
kitty's stories in check so i tend to
spend a couple of months to get to a
certain level and then they jump right
into difficult stuff slog my way through
where there's 30 40 percent unknown
words and i save those words in linkedin
and we'll review them and then listen
and read again and listen and read again
and slowly i just keep grinding through
and because the actual
content is interesting to me
i i have a great sense of relation that
i'm reading about czech history if it's
czech or or politics and now i'm into
korean and so basically that's it you
you fight your way through initially uh
initially very simple and uninteresting
material as quickly as possible you
hopefully get into interesting material
but with a high level of unknown words
you fight your way through those reading
and listen you know listening and
reading and listening until there's
fewer and fewer unknown words there and
then gradually it becomes more and more
pleasant and and you're on your way and
the thing about words is that the more
words you know
the more words you can infer and the
more you know the more interesting
content you can expose yourself to and
therefore acquire more and more words so
it's a bit of a snowball so there you
have it on acquiring words i hope that
answers the question thank you bye for
now